Zoom fatigue is taking its toll on your
health this is according to a report
published in the journal scientific
reports looked for physiological signs
of fatigue in 35 students attending
lectures on engineering at an Austrian
University they found that there were
notable differences between the
in-person and the online groups the
study found that video participants
fatigue mounted over the course of the
session their brain states showed that
they were struggling to pay attention
the group's moods varied as well
in-person participants reported feeling
livelier happier and more active online
participants said they felt tired drowsy
and fed up of course it doesn't take a
scientific study to know that human
beings prefer to do things in person
than virtually